the tragedy that you often see in in
works of literature is that someone's
trying their best to do what they
believe to be the right thing and
everything works around them to shift
the terms of the reality and that's kind
of also what's happening to us when we
try to navigate shifting realities
online and everything kind of changes
and we're not quite sure of the rules of
the game that we're being induced to
play and you can see that with Hamlet
that he gets the message from the ghost
you know I'm your dead dad go and kill
your uncle and he's constantly trying to
reason with this actually really
unreasonable set of circumstances which
is that he's in a Revenge tragedy and
he's got to just kill everyone but he's
trying to make rational decisions and I
think we really have that online that
there's a kind of strange digital
Paradox that's going on where
something's happening that we don't
quite understand the loss of the time
but we're being denied the ultimate
rationality